on voit là une information qui va mettre
à mal la mauvaise image qu'on accroche
souvent aux villes de banlieue une
grande agence de notation internationale
en l'occurrence moody's qui
s'intéressent d'habitude aux états unis
à la grèce ou à l'irlande vient
d'attribuer un double à à la ville de
clichy sous bois
c'est une belle performance pour une
commune confronté à de lourdes
difficultés françoise valais david
fossard clichy sous bois
c'est pavillon et ses grands immeubles
une ville pauvre de l'est parisien bien
noté par une agence internationale les
clichois ne reviennent pas surpris que
une agence internationale puisse altérer
ses cours remonté de 18 mois quand on
espère d'emplois antichi a eu pas mal de
rénovation face et reconstruire la ville
mais surtout changer son image
souvenez-vous des émeutes de 2005 en
région parisienne elle était partie
d'ici l'équipe municipale a investi dans
un contexte difficile la majorité des
trente mille habitants ne sont pas
imposables comme pour un état
lagence donc regarder les dépenses les
recettes mais surtout la capacité de la
ville à rembourser ses dettes
résultat double a comme lyon la note
rassure des investisseurs et permet
d'emprunter à des taux d'intérêt les
plus bas du marché
là vous voyez par exemple c'est une
claque qui vient d'ouvrir pour qui a
coûté plus de 6 millions d'euros et
qu'on n'aurait pas pu construire sans
ses efforts de gestion et ses
subventions
c'est le maire qui a demandé la notation
j'en avais vraiment à ses dents tant que
la ville de clichy où d'autres villes de
banlieue étaient pauvres parce qu'elle
était mal gérée et alors que l'on avait
fait son pot pour raisons structurelles
de manque de recherche de recettes
donc je me suis dit comment démontrer
que cette ville est bien gérée et de
montrer de façon nous discutable et j'ai
demandé donc une adresse une agence de
notation de mono pts et avec sa bonne
note la ville a pu lancer un programme
de 20 millions d'euros
clichy sous bois est désormais réputé
pour sa solidité financière